more than 130 countries reached deal on
corporate minimum tax
uh they have agreed on sweeping changes
on how big global companies are taxed
including 15 minimum corporate rate
designed to deter multinationals from
stashing profits and low tax countries
the deal announced friday as an attempt
to address the ways globalization and
digitalization have changed the world
economy the agreement amongst 136
countries representing 90 percent of
global economy was announced by the
paris
based organization for cooperation and
economic development which hosted the
talks that led to it the oecd said that
the minimum tax would reap some 150
billion dollars for governments the
global minimum tax at 15 would apply to
companies that with more uh with more
than uh 864 billion dollars in revenue i
think that's a million i don't think
that no no that's a billion that's
that's annual that's worldwide billion
that is billion of course uh it's going
to go from 150 billion to 864 billion if
they apply this 15
corporate minimum tax across 130
countries who have agreed thoughts
here's what i want you to do because i
think as the only one who is a full-on
business owner corporate business owner
why don't you give us the good the bad
the ugly of this because you've been
pretty opinionated i don't think this
has to do i think this has to do more
with uh who who doesn't get to compete
okay so think about this how many
planets do we have to how many options
do we have on planets to live on today
what the earth and mars mars is coming
why shouldn't you elon left his person
so he's probably gonna he's probably got
a little bit more time to focus on
because his girl was a little bit of a
distraction maybe so but we only have
one planet right i agree okay how many
countries do we have on this planet what
200 let's say 200 countries give or take
sometimes 195 sometimes 220. let's say
200 right okay so if all of these guys
all of a sudden agree on the same
corporate minimum tax rate where do you
go if you're not happy somewhere
where do you go
what's your option now what's your
choice now what do you do now it's the
same what are the countries that aren't
signing on to this i guess that's that's
that's that's right and by the way the
one country that apple google what was
the one country they're all in ireland
right yeah now they were 12 and a half
percent they're also agreeing and they
finally went to 15 15. so what did what
why are they so excited about doing this
ask that question why are you so excited
about raising the corporate tax rate
where's i think i think yeah they want
to find out what is it though what's the
motive what's the real motive to want to
do something like this i think the a
term you always use is a race to the
bottom so like uh
hungary is at nine percent ireland's
been at 12 and a half percent you have
countries like russia saudi arabia
and uh china i think was at 25 then you
have the majority of the g7 countries
somewhere around like 25 27
so
i think
you always hear an item not a corporate
tax finance guy you know that's not my
thing but you always hear about
amazon pays zero in taxes apple pays
zero in taxes
how are they getting away with this then
you hear the argument that
you you i remember you did it on the
white board with me like why are we
paying any corporate taxes because taxes
are individuals are taxed yeah i think
it's just a complicated payroll tax yeah
all that so that's why i you know
the optics of it it's not only double
tax you're getting triple taxes tax on
taxes it's non-stop it's you know the
money you're making you're paying taxes
on the income you're paying tax on
corporate you're paying taxes on sales
you're paying by the time you really
come to come down to what money stays
with you it's not as big as people think
it is now what the whole thing with zero
percent zero percent taxes they're
talking about is how a company was worth
a half a billion dollars a half a
trillion dollars now it's a 700 billion
dollar company they haven't spent the
money they've made 200 billion dollars
we should tax that
you know valuation of the company that
went up or your net worth went up we
should tax that additional what that you
made you didn't do anything with the
money you haven't taken it out it's just
your net worth's gone up right not even
capital gains there's not been an
exchange yet for the stocks to they want
to add taxes to that but i'm asking
another question here
why do you think they're so excited
about raising and making it equal to
everybody
why are they doing that what's the
motive there well when you
want people to stop smoking you increase
the price of cigarettes through taxes
when you want people to stop drinking
you increase the price of vice through
taxes you want people to get off of gas
and become carbon neutral you increase
the price i think that this is something
you talked about the small business
owner before
this is again one of their things where
only
many few few few international
corporations are going to be able to
take on the extra three four percent in
tax in addition by the way to the taxes
that they have for import and export i
mean that was one of the big things that
we have with trying china was the trade
deficit this is something i was
completely wrong about this is something
i've changed my mind 180 degrees on i
used to be completely supply side and i
said i don't care if there's a trade
deficit i don't care if china taxes our
companies 40
to import there and they and we tax them
nothing to import here that helps me the
consumer i can have six dollar underwear
instead of nine dollar on their
underwear that helps me yeah right get
your third pair under where every time
you're wrong yeah yeah off your
girlfriend's floor adam boom
yeah anyway the so the point last night
would you have a good time with that i
did yeah you ditched us it better been
good we want details did she really come
visit us
[Laughter]
as you were saying about corporate taxes
came to check on the cats adam we were
hanging out
yeah dude long story short man like only
massive companies that have
serious government in interconnection
are going to be able to handle this on a
national level
so yeah
what's this year let me see what's going
on here i never knew that corporate tax
would be this risque yeah there's a lot
of a lot of
underpants at the end of the day like we
always talk about competition i mean
big business they can compete small
can't
um that's going to affect a lot of
people's way of living especially in
some of these smaller countries you know
one of the things that i've been able to
do you know being a professional
bodybuilder
was a travel world um
who's going to cheat
is what i'm thinking oh yeah you know
that's what i'm thinking right now
you know like who's going to think
china's going to play fair yeah great
25 percent okay so they're not in it so
are there allies is china's allies the
big domino to drop here was ireland
because ireland was was like the tax
haven for all these
major corporations at 12 and a half
percent yours and they weren't there
they want a one-world government so bad
dude and they can't see it i mean this
shows it right i mean that's exactly
what this is this is that's where is
that
that's the direction i mean where's the
money gonna go essentially how do they
enforce it
right
how do they enforce what how do they
enforce this yeah yeah
what do you mean how do they enforce it
let's say we have the irs yeah but are
you talking about outside everybody each
of these countries have their own taxes
each of these countries is going to get
their money it's not going to be
skirting the tax laws anymore i think
that that seems to be the bottom line
all these tax loopholes and paying zero
taxes sorry corporate uh corporations
time to pay so that seems to be the big
win for yelling advising basically i
said so basically a country like let's
just say spain they say okay
adam uh you did in our country five
million dollars or whatever where here's
your bill and then i took a siesta
guys 150 to 8.95 that's how much is uh
increasing 150 to 8.95 that's a solid
amount that's 6x overnight okay and
collecting taxes it's not a bad deal
right there to make that kind of money
kai are you trying to say something
yeah i don't know how how long this is
going to go through because the thing
with cartels like that where everyone
has to be in agreement the only
successful cartel there's really been
over an extended period of time is opec
which controls the oil prices but with
here all you need is one outlier to just
drop through and then all the countries
are suddenly going to start falling to
that country and they're going to be
making a lot of money that way so well
there's already countries that haven't
signed on to this yeah 136 companies uh
countries have we're representing what
ninety percent of the global economy
there's still ten percent lingering out
there so if you want to go business and
business in bangladesh have at it
one of the major economies is not in it
i don't know no can you see if you can
pull it up in in like
30 seconds
just think about though just think about
how
is this bad any improvement is this a
bad thing great benevolent government
so why would all these countries go go
sign on to this because they're greedy
and because they're working towards uh
you know
i don't think i don't think that
countries that want to uh
get that money are greedy they want that
tax revenue that's what that is greed
for what that's greed well it's the uh
we all want our money yeah we're all
greedy
taking tax revenue from what the people
that are earning the the money the
corporations right they're earning money
it's not like they're using so what are
they going to use this money for
whatever the hell they want as their
government right exactly kenya nigerian
pakistan and sri lanka
so if you want to go to business kenya
sri lanka pakistan supporters have added
yeah out of the out of the oecd the only
four countries that said no is kenyan
nigeria pakistan and sri lanka okay
which is uh you ain't got a lot of
options yeah anyone trying to go do
business there no you ain't got a lot of
options there but i hear night life in
sri lanka is actually not bad
i hear the djibouti is where it's at
though so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]